>> SCOTT: ...Integration between GeoStudio
and Google Apps. We thought, "Well, what if
the applications themselves could talk with
you?" And that's what we built. Here you can
see that we'll get a notification from our
build system. And our build systems let us
know that the build that we're interested
in has failed. Now, I can click through from
this failure message and see the build itself,
and find out why it failed and who's responsible.
We can see here that it was Dan who broke
the build, and he got his own instant message,
and I'm sure he's already working hard to
fix it. Here we go. So on the left-hand side
you can see-- instantly linked through to
all the applications in Google Apps, as well
as Studio. We can see the recent Google Docs,
such as the design specification we attached
recently. We can see our upcoming calendar,
and without leaving studio, we can create
an event. So we need to create that meeting
with Dan at 9:00 p.m.? Well, I guess 9:00
tomorrow morning, and, uh, we can quickly
add that, and make sure it doesn't conflict
with our other important meetings we have
coming up. Without leaving studio, we can
see our upcoming Gmail events, and see--Gmail
messages, and see if there's anything we need
to respond to. We can see the code views that
are assigned to us. I think Dan has assigned
me a code view to work on. The builds that
have failed, such as the one we've just seen.
And we can see our favorite Wiki pages, as
well as recent JIRA issues. Now, the thing
that's most important for me is the final
tab, which gives you a single view across
all the applications of the things that are
relevant to me and my team. So we've shown
you gadgets in Studio and inside Gmail. We've
shown you the power of Google Docs. We've
shown you Google Talk and the fingertip access
to all the applications. And that's just some
of the integrations that we've built, and
best of all, it's available today. In fact,
it's in use already. In fact, it's being used
by 40 developers in a bus traveling 60 miles
an hour, from San Francisco to South by Southwest.
Along the way they're committing code using
the system, and they're using Google Apps
and the Studio integration, and they'll be
launching three startups when they arrive
at South by Southwest. So we think, you know,
this combination of products is fantastic
for startups and software development companies
alike, and we look forward to you using it.
Thank you, Dave. [pause]
>> DAVE: Thank you, Scott. So you saw how
by using a variety of different extension
points, Atlassian was able to connect the
entire surface area of their software development
suite with the entire surface area of Google's
communication and collaboration suite, so
that all the employees of our joint customers,
whether they spend most of their time on one
side of the fence in the land of email, or
on the other side of the fence in the land
of code, have full access to all the information
they need, when they need it. The next demo
I'd like to show you, I'm gonna invite up
Amit from Manymoon, who's gonna show you how
by using the Google Apps Marketplace, and
the extension with--the integration with Google
Apps was how a startup was able to build many
more features for their customers much more
quickly than they would have been able to
otherwise. Amit.
>> AMIT: Great. Thanks, David. Hello, I'm
Amit Kulkarni with Manymoon, and, uh, Manymoon
is a social productivity application that
helps teams get work done online. And what
I'd like to show you today is how we used
OpenID, Google Calendar, Contacts, and the
Docs APIs that quickly develop features that
our customers were asking for, while converting
a lot of our free users to paid users. And
what we're really excited about today is the
new Google Apps Marketplace, because it dramatically
simplifies how users can access the Manymoon
Google Apps integration. So let's dive right
into the demo. So this is a typical Google
Apps user. Her name is Kate. And she's received
an urgent email from her manager, Jim, saying
that they have to move to a new office at
the end of the month. And he wants the status
by the end of the day. Kate turns to Manymoon
to make this happen. So she'll get started
by accessing Manymoon from within the Google
universal navigation. And with just one click,
she's brought right into the application.
So there's no need for her to register or
sign up again. She's got a variety of features
available to her, but she's already got a
workspace available called New Office Move
that she'll access. And first things first,
she'll create a task that says, "Select which
office to move to." And we've integrated with
the Google Contacts and Provisioning APIs,
so it's really easy for her to assign these
tasks. She'll just put in someone's name,
and Manymoon will auto-complete-- Find the
person, and auto-complete it for her. And
that's it. Now, luckily, Kate's been keeping
track of a list of offices and a Google Spreadsheet
that she would like to attach to this task.
So she'll go to "Attach, List Google Docs,"
and using the Google Doc List API will bring
up a list of her Google Docs and uploaded
files, so you see a spreadsheet here, List
of Office Spaces, and that's it. She's added
it to the task. She'll give this task a due
date. And say we want to get this done by
the end of the week. And that's how easy it
is for her to create a task and automatically
share that Google Spreadsheet with Jim, using
the Google Docs APIs. Now, most projects have
multiple people, so she'll want to invite
someone to help out, so she'll go to the members
section, and she'll add someone. So, in this
case, she'll add myself, Amit, to help out
with the office move. And that's it. But here's
the really cool part. Now that I'm a member
of this project, I automatically have access
to that Google Spreadsheet she just attached
a second ago. Because Manymoon uses the Google
Docs sharing APIs. So as a project member,
I no longer have to go around asking for permission
to access data that's relevant to me. Manymoon
and Google Apps take care of all of that.
So after releasing these initial integrations,
we knew customers really liked these capabilities,
because our baseline of daily visits increased
by 300%, which we were ecstatic about, obviously.
Okay, so Kate's assigned a task to her manager,
she's invited someone to help with the office
move. Now she wants to give this a deadline,
and give everyone a graphical calendar view
to keep them focused. Now, typically, building
a full-blown calendar capability might take
months. We were able to do it in just a couple
of weeks using Google Calendar. Let me show
you how. So she'll go to Edit, and she'll
give this office move a deadline of the end
of the month, just like her manager asked,
and that's it. She'll now go down to the calendar
section, which is in actuality a Google Calendar
that we've embedded and integrated right within
Manymoon. So that task that you just created
with a due date is here. That deadline that
she created is right here as well. And this
calendar has all the features that our customers
need, so we as a development team can focus
on building team workflow software, instead
of worrying about building features of our
own calendar software, like reminders and
so on. And because we share the same information
with Google Apps, her manager, who had originally
asked for the status by the end of the day,
he lives and dies in his Google Calendar,
which I'll show you here, and I'll refresh
it. He can see the same information instantaneously,
without ever going to a third-party application.
So I've shown you just a little bit of what
Manymoon can do, and how integrating with
Google Apps helped us very quickly meet market
requirements. And, you know, customers love
this integration. We've got thousands of businesses
using Manymoon for everything from event-planning
to software-development, to hiring and recruiting.
And, as you see, the Google Apps marketplace
dramatically simplifies how users like Kate
can access Manymoon, and then also utilize
their existing Google Apps within Manymoon.
Thanks, and I'll turn it back over to David.
[pause]
>> DAVID: Thank you, Amit. What you saw again,
take a startup. Wants to build an awful lot
of features for her customers, wants to build
them in a hurry with a small team. Let's stand
on the shoulders of giants. Let's take advantage
of Google Apps, and use the integration points
and the Marketplace to accelerate their ability,
force multiplier, and their ability to build
a great product in a hurry, and expand the
power of Google Apps with more features for
more users. Before I bring up our last demo,
want to talk about one extension point. Remember
I said we have a list of opportunities for
integration, and the list is going to be growing?
Well, everything you've seen so far tonight
is going to be live, available for installation
and purchase later this evening. What we're
about to show you is one sneak peek of one
of the new integration points that's coming.
It's not available yet, but it's available
to you as developers to start trying out,
start thinking about and building into your
apps, and say, "Hey, what would I do with
this?" This is the ability to get one step
deeper into the flow of your user's life inside
Google Apps. If any of you are Gmail users,
you've probably noticed that recently when
someone sends you an email that just contains
in the text of the email a link to a YouTube
video, something in Gmail somehow noticed
that there was something of interest there,
matched on that link to the YouTube video,
and inserted into your inbox, right in line
in the email, a little preview widget, little
gadget that said, "Hey, here's something that
might be of use to you right now, because
I matched on something that I was told to
look for in the email." Well, we took the
machinery that our internal teams had used
to build that triggering into their application
integration with Gmail, and we're making it
available to you as developers to include
into your apps. So what this means is that
your application can say, "I'm interested
in a particular field, in a particular email.
Whenever an email arrives that, for example,
contains the name of--in the from field is
from one of the people in my customer database,
I want to match on that, have my application
get called, so I have the opportunity to show
my users the information they need, give them
an opportunity to take action on that information,
right in place." Sort of point-of-action information
right there in their inbox. That contextual
gadget capability is what our last demo tonight,
Appirio, is going to show us. I'd like to
invite up Ryan from Appirio, who is going
to show you how using some of the points of
integration that you've seen before, and the
new, contextual gadget capability, was able
to build a very tight integration between
Appirio's product and Google Apps. Ryan.
>> RYAN: Great.